between the chocolate peanut butter the
chocolate caramel it makes for the
ultimate dessert i'm natalie potter and
i'm laura potter we're bliss and baker
and we're back at tasty to share our
halloween inspired rice krispie treat i
remember being a little kid and having
all this leftover candy weeks and weeks
later and so incorporating all that
leftover candy into our favorite dessert
is the perfect solution we're using the
standard crispy treat recipe with just a
touch of vanilla so that your favorite
candies can be the star of the show we
recommend using your favorite chocolate
candy over something gummy or sour
because we feel like it just complements
the rice krispies treat better so we're
going to start with the salted butter in
a non-stick pot or in this case a
cauldron once the butter is melted pour
in the mini marshmallows and just stir
it occasionally until they're all
completely melted it's really important
to melt the mini marshmallows on low to
prevent them from burning we prefer to
use the mini marshmallows over the large
ones because they melt much faster and
more evenly now it's time to add the
cereal and fold to combine seriously
this is my favorite part i love to see
it all come together now we're scooping
half the mixture into a prepared pan and
you really want to try to cover the
entire bottom of the pan so that the
candy doesn't fall through we think this
is the perfect recipe to make with your
kids post trick-or-treating and it's a
great way to get your kids to share
their candy with you we love this recipe
because of the contrast between the
vanilla and the chocolate and now you
can sprinkle your favorite chocolate
candies on top now we're going to spread
the rest of the mixture on top you can
use a spatula or even a little bit of
nonstick spray on your hands after we
chopped our chocolate we put it in the
freezer for a bit so it wouldn't melt
into the warm rice krispie treat mixture
as if there wasn't enough candy already
in there we're going to sprinkle a
little bit more on top so the candy
lover in me wants to eat these right now
but you're going to have to let them sit
at room temperature for two hours or in
the fridge for an hour before you can
cut them trust me they're worth the wait
oh my gosh look at these seriously look
at those layers chocolate crispy more
candy so good i don't know about you
guys but we love halloween well we love
candy we love candy so much we each have
a secret stash hidden away in our desk
drawers at the office
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
you